die aktuelle pandemie hat gezeigt dass
wir in einer großen krise schnell
handeln und schlimmes verhindern können
die regierung hat sich dabei von
expertinnen und experten beraten lassen
und auf der basis von wissenschaftlichen
erkenntnissen entscheidungen getroffen
es liegt zwar bei weitem nicht alles
perfekt aber im großen und ganzen ist
die deutsche bevölkerung mit den
massnahmen zufrieden
wann wir mit dieser krise fertig sind
das kann heute noch keiner sagen was wir
aber wissen ist dass uns eine andere
noch bevorsteht
der klimawandel diese krise kommt nicht
so plötzlich und hat keine so direkt
sichtbaren dramatischen konsequenzen die
globale erwärmung wirkt auf die meisten
menschen noch nicht wie eine katastrophe
die unmittelbares handeln erfordert das
ist sie aber
und sobald sie wie eine katastrophe
wirkt ist es bereits zu spät
was können wir also tun um auch diese
bedrohung rechtzeitig abzuwenden könnte
die aktuelle krise ein vorbild sein
die wissenschaft und regierung enger
zusammenarbeiten können oder noch weiter
gedacht wäre eine regierung nur aus
wissenschaftlern in der lage die
klimakrise zu verhindern
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
auf doktor watson und vergesst nicht den
kanal zu abonnieren und kein neues video
zu verpassen
ich bin ein mann der zahlen und ich
kenne das behalten was wird nicht
passieren und es passiert leider nicht
fucking feiern
es gibt eine ganze menge sachen in die
ziemlich sicher sind und deshalb müssen
wir dem rat stark
sie schafft folgen
wahrheit
ist das einzige kapital der wissenschaft
dieses video ist eine koproduktion mit
arte und den 10
wir wollen hiermit auf es wird zeit
aufmerksam machen das ist eine
europaweite interaktive echtzeit umfrage
die sich vor allem an junge menschen
richtet
dort geht es um die globale erwärmung
und den umweltschutz aber auch fragen
zum selbstbild und der digitalisierung
werden gestellt und ein paar dieser
fragen haben mich dazu inspiriert ein
gedankenexperiment aufzustellen
wie würde die wissenschaft deutschland
regieren und vor allem könnte sie den
klimawandel aufhalten
[Musik]
natürlich muss ich erst mal erwähnen
dass sich dieses gedankenspiel nur auf
deutschland bezieht effektive klima
bemühungen müssen aber global
organisiert werden alleine wird
deutschland den klimawandel nicht
aufhalten können wir brauchen die
unterstützung von den größten klima was
nutzern wie china und den usa
trotzdem kann deutschland natürlich mit
gutem beispiel vorangehen und einen
unterschied machen und nur weil andere
mehr co2 ausstoßen
ist das noch lange keine rechtfertigung
dass weiterhin selber zu tun
außerdem muss man sagen dass es nicht
die eine wissenschaft gibt die immer
eine aussage trifft und immer recht hat
wissenschaft basiert auf ergebnissen und
mehrere wissenschaftler können zu
unterschiedlichen schlussfolgerungen
kommen wissenschaft wird sich immer
weiter entwickeln und verändern und das
ist nichts schlechtes
dadurch bleibt sie immer auf dem
neuesten stand und im optimalfall
entsteht dabei ein dialog deswegen ist
die fragestellung dieses videos wie ich
finde super spannend wissenschaftler
zeichnen sich vor allem durch großes
fachwissen methodisches vorgehen und
sauberes argumentieren aus die debatten
und entscheidungen einer wissenschafts
regierung würden wahrscheinlich komplett
anders aussehen als die von heutigen
politikern unsere demokratie verfolgt
beispielsweise ein checks and balances
system das heißt eine instanz
kontrolliert die andere in der
wissenschaft ist das nicht so
dort werden nicht institutionen sondern
die ergebnisse kontrolliert so kann die
wissenschaftsgemeinschaft fakten
etablieren und auf grundlage dieser
fakten wurde eine wissenschafts
regierung dann politik machen
für unser gedankenexperiment gehen wir
mal davon aus dass deutschland zur
bekämpfung des klimawandels die
kontrolle an eine liga von
wissenschaftlern übergibt
[Musik]
diese wissenschaftler sind experten auf
allen möglichen gebieten meteorologie
natürlich aber auch energie
ingenieurwesen wirtschaftswissenschaften
und politikwissenschaften oder auch
psychologie sollte alles dabei seien
alle bereiche sollten abgedeckt werden
bei einem ersten treffen versammelt sich
diese liga und dann muss sie sich
natürlich einen plan überlegen
das ist immerhin die grundlage von
wissenschaftlichem denken eine frage
oder ein problem wird identifiziert und
soweit in einzelteile zerlegt bis man
diese frage beantworten kann
klima und umweltschutz ist aber extrem
facettenreich und wahrscheinlich wäre es
gar nicht so einfach sich zu entscheiden
mit welchen problemen sie anfangen
wollen
wahrscheinlich würde es zu großen
debatten kommen massentierhaltung co2
ausstoß öffentliche gesundheit
landschafts erhaltung biologischer sieht
die liszt ist ziemlich lang aber viele
probleme stehen tatsächlich in kausalem
zusammenhang mit der globalen erwärmung
und ein faktor scheint dabei zentral zu
sein
co2 massentierhaltung geht zum beispiel
mit der rodung von wäldern einher und
erzeugt treibhausgase die rodung von
wäldern sorgt dafür dass dort weniger
co2 gespeichert werden kann
und gerade das holz wird per schiff über
den atlantik transportiert wieder co2 es
würde also sinn ergeben genau dort
anzusetzen
massentierhaltung der energiesektor und
so gut wie jedes produkt wohl sagt co2
emissionen
denn egal ob es der eine kleidung dein
smartphone oder ein auto ist die
bedeutende mehrheit unserer konsumgüter
wird mit hilfe von fossilen brennstoffen
produziert und dann zu dir befördert wie
würde unsere liga der wissenschaftler
hierfür große veränderungen sorgen
können unsere aktuelle regierung besitzt
nicht die entscheidungsgewalt
unternehmen zu nachhaltiger produktion
zu verpflichten
der markt ist aktuell größtenteils frei
und soll nach kapitalistischen maximen
nicht von außen reguliert werden
deswegen haben politiker in den
vergangenen jahren versucht für
wirtschaftliche anreize zu sorgen damit
firmen sich freiwillig umstrukturieren
im ersten schritt wurde wahrscheinlich
auch unsere wissenschaftler regierung
hier mitarbeiten nur wahrscheinlich
wesentlich mehr denn es hat sich gezeigt
dass das prinzip generell gut
funktioniert nur oft wird es zu zaghaft
eingesetzt sie könnten zum beispiel für
fördermittel und aufträge vom staat
voraussetzen dass nachhaltig produziert
werden muss oder fördern dass
arbeitgeber ihren mitarbeitern fahrräder
zur verfügung stellen oder bahncards
oder glasfaser damit man von zu hause
aus arbeiten kann
das sind alles vorsichtige schritte in
die richtige richtung die auch teilweise
schon umgesetzt wurden
aber was wenn das wie jetzt gerade nicht
ausreicht denn egal wie viele anreize
und fördergelder gegeben werden firmen
müssen profitabel sein
solange eine umweltfreundliche
produktion nicht für schwarzen zahlen
sorgt gibt es für unternehmen da keinen
grund sich umzustrukturieren
denn das kostet geld und mühen deswegen
haben viele industrieverbände einen
starken lobby apparat der maßgeblich
einfluss auf die gesetzgebung nimmt ok
also nicht okay aber okay wenn der freie
markt dem klimaschutz im weg steht
könnte eine wissenschaftler regierung
die wirtschaft vielleicht härter
regulieren
anstatt also positive anreize zu
schaffen müsste sie einen härteren weg
einschlagen umweltschädliches verteuern
bisher wurde klimaschutz in erster linie
von menschen finanziert die freiwillig
mehr zahlen um etwas gutes zu tun zum
beispiel ökostromtarife elektroautos
oder die co2 kompensation beim fliegen
so wird man aber leider nie alle
menschen gleichermaßen an den kosten des
klimaschutzes beteiligen
es wird immer noch mehr als genug leute
geben die sich aus finanziellen gründen
oder aus unwissenheit für eine
klimaschädliche variante entscheiden
hier muss man aber auch dazu sagen oft
können wir gar nicht genug einblick in
die produktion von unseren produkten wie
zum beispiel kleidung oder unseren
smartphones gewinnen
gerechter wäre es also die kosten des
klimaschutzes von denjenigen bezahlen zu
lassen
die den schaden verursachen die liga der
wissenschaftler
könnte einen co2 preis erheben dh dass
firmen sich emissionsrechte kaufen
müssten um co2 ausstoßen zu dürfen nur
durch co2 intensive produkte teurer und
unattraktiver werden
und wenn man die einnahmen aus dem co2
preis dann in die förderung
klimafreundliche alternativen steckt
dann führt das sogar zu einem doppelten
hebel klimaschädliche produkte werden
teurer
klimafreundliche alternativen dagegen
günstiger das bedeutet für konsumenten
durch die klimafreundliche variante
gleichzeitig auch die günstigere
variante und klimaschädliche produkte
für ein langfristig von ganz alleine auf
dem markt von co2 preisen abgesehen sind
auch andere gesetzliche maßnahmen
möglich zum beispiel könnte die liga der
wissenschaftler
maximale co2 emission und für autos pro
kilometer festlegen
das gibt es zwar heute schon könnte aber
noch deutlich konsequenter sein dass das
genau bedeutet dazu komme ich gleich
noch mal
für manche industrien könnte das aber
ganz schön teuer sein
kreuzfahrten oder der globale
flugverkehr würden so weniger gewinn
machen
es gibt es doch schon das erste
kreuzfahrtschiff und brennstoffzellen
flugzeuge aber ein flächendeckender
umstieg lässt noch auf sich warten und
ein radikales umdenken von jetzt auf
gleich könnte auf der anderen seite
super gefährlich sein
millionen von jobs sind von
umweltschädlicher produktion abhängig
eine menge menschen könnten ihre arbeit
verlieren
auf der anderen seite stehen mindestens
genauso viele jobs auf dem spiel wenn
wir keine veränderungen anstoßen
laut einer studie weltweit mindestens 80
millionen alleine bis 2030 nur aufgrund
des klimawandels aber das gute ist
wandel und innovation können immer noch
neue jobs hervorbringen ok selbst wenn
unsere liga der wissenschaft es schafft
die industrie klimaneutral zu gestalten
es sieht noch lange nicht am ziel dann
werden zum beispiel langfristig keine
umweltschädlichen geräte mehr produziert
ja trotzdem besitzt ein großteil der
bevölkerung aber noch gasheizungen und
verbrenner autos mit denen sie jeden tag
heizen oder um heizen
der schnellste weg hier die co2
emissionen zu verringern während
verboten das heißt autofreie innenstädte
oder tempolimits zum beispiel auch diese
sind nicht unumstritten sollte es soweit
kommen steht die liga der
wissenschaftler vor einer entscheidung
was ist wichtiger klimaschutz oder
persönliche und wirtschaftliche freiheit
und das ist wirklich keine einfache
entscheidung denn generell geht mit
diesen änderungen eine radikale
gesetzgebung einher fiel dieser lösungen
könnten mit sicherheit von firmen oder
bundesbürgern mit dem grundgesetz
angeklagt werden
und schon in der vergangenheit hatte es
oft gut gemeinte gesetze mit ungeahnten
teilweise komplett gegensätzlichen
folgen in der praxis gegeben
autobauer sind zum beispiel in der eu
gesetzlich verpflichtet dafür zu sorgen
dass ihre verkauften autos im
durchschnitt einen bestimmten
emissionsgrenzwerte nicht überschreiten
dieser grenzwerte sind mit der zeit
immer weiter so dass die autobauer
gezwungen sind ihre fahrzeuge
effizienter zu gestalten
die eu verordnung erst 2009 hat aber
nicht so richtig mit elektroautos
gerechnet denn jetzt wo viele e-autos
mit ihren geringen emissionen den
flottendurchschnitt stark beeinflussen
können hersteller mit den werten
jonglieren das konventionelle autos
teilweise wieder mehr ausstoßen dürfen
der teufel die tier also im detail
konsequenterweise müsste man die
elektroautos für die emissionsgrenzwerte
eigentlich getrennt betrachten
damit der verbesserungs druck für
herkömmlich verbrenner hoch bleibt
[Musik]
führende klimaforscher warnen davor dass
wir nur noch zehn jahre haben um die
erwärmung auf ein maximum von 15 grad zu
begrenzen wenn wir das nicht schaffen
und danach sieht es aktuell sehr aus
würde jedes weitere halbe grad das
risiko von dürren überflutungen und
extremer hitze und infolgedessen armut
für hunderte millionen menschen
signifikant erhöhen
die zeit ist also extrem knapp und sie
wird jeden tag knapp müsste unsere
regierung aus wissenschaftlern also
vielleicht an der demokratie
vorbeiregieren um schlimmeres zu
verhindern
demokratische strukturen verkomplizieren
und verlangsamen immerhin schnelle
lösungen und für die bekämpfung der
pandemie wurden ja auch grund gesetze
außer kraft gesetzt zu unserem schutz
langfristig kann das aber eine ganz
schöne zerreißprobe für die bevölkerung
darstellen demokratische strukturen
mögen ein hindernis besonders für
schnelle änderungen seien sie erfüllen
aber einen sehr wichtigen zweck unsere
freiheiten sind wichtige
errungenschaften die nicht leichtfertig
und langfristig außer kraft gesetzt
werden dürfen
selbst die wohlwollens der diktatur ist
am ende immer noch eine diktatur und mit
radikalen änderungen und eingriffen in
das leben und die wirtschaft verspielt
sich eine wissenschaftler regierung
wahrscheinlich jede regierung auf diesem
planeten das vertrauen und das
verständnis des volkes es ist also
wahrscheinlich keine gute idee einfach
im schnelldurchlauf gesetze zu
verabschieden
aber wie kann unsere liga dann den
klimawandel stoppen
je länger ich über das potenzial einer
wissenschafts regierung nachgedacht habe
desto mehr ist mir klar geworden dass zu
wissen was uns theoretisch auf den
richtigen weg bringt nicht alles ist die
klügsten und renommiertesten forscher an
die spitze eines landes zu stellen ist
leider keine universallösung
denn auch wenn der klimawandel dieses
jahrhundert wahrscheinlich die größte
aufgabe für die menschheit sein wird
macht das tagespolitische geschehen da
keine pause es ist wichtig dass wir eine
vielzahl an ministerinnen und ministern
mit unterschiedlichen schwerpunkten und
hintergründen haben und auch
wissenschaftler fühlen sich vielleicht
im labor wohler als hinterm rednerpult
aus meiner sicht wäre die vielleicht
größte waffe zur bekämpfung des
klimawandels eine solidarische und
informierte gesellschaft denn wenn wir
nicht alle an einem strang ziehen um die
globale erderwärmung zu stoppen dann
legen wir uns gegenseitig nur noch
steine in den weg
wenn wir alle wüssten wie schlimm es um
und steht dann wären verbote gar nicht
mehr notwendig wenn keiner mehr suv
kauft dann muss die industrie von
alleine umstellen
und wenn keiner mehr fleisch essen will
dann denkt sich die gastronomie neue
vegetarische gerichte aus die enge
zusammenarbeit von wissenschaft und
politik in der pandemie ist wegweisend
für unsere zukunft das braucht
expertengremien für den klimawandel
denen man aber auch zuhören muss die
alleinige kontrolle an wissenschaftler
abzugeben wird wenig erfolgreich sein
denn vielleicht genauso wichtig wie das
erkennen und lösen von problemen ist es
für verständnis in der gesellschaft zu
sorgen und das ist sicher keine leichte
aufgabe
dafür braucht es gute kommunikation und
fingerspitzengefühl
aber das ist vielleicht die wichtigste
aufgabe unserer zeit
[Musik]
falls ihr euch jetzt fragt was es mit
dem projekt es wird zeit auf sich hat
das kann ich euch gerne erklären es wird
zeit ist ein interaktives projekt mit
videos von anderen kräutern und diesem
video hier auch und vor allem einer
großen umfrage das coole an der umfrage
ist dass die ergebnisse in echtzeit
angezeigt werden die umfrage ist für die
junge generation also für jugendliche
und junge erwachsene wie uns und wir
wollen uns eine stimme gegeben das ziel
besteht darin dass ihr euch ausdrücken
und angesichts der gewaltigen
herausforderungen die vor uns liegen
positionieren könnten fragen habt ihr
die möglichkeit eure meinung über unsere
gesellschaft und das was sie durchmacht
ausdruck zu verleihen
die zeit ist gekommen dass man euch zu
hört also nutzt das medium um eure
meinung kundzutun geht jetzt auf arte tv
es wird zeit und füllt den interaktiven
fragebogen aus
das macht auch mal zeigt euch mal wie
das so aussieht und werde mal ein paar
fragen beantworten nämlich genau die
fragen die mich zu diesem video hier
inspiriert haben
für den planeten würde ich prioritär
folgende verbote akzeptieren ja verboten
hat schon darüber gesprochen generell
schwierig ich glaube ich würde ein
plastik verbot akzeptieren ich glaube es
gibt genug alternativen materialien
abgesehen von der medizin dazu hatte ich
auch schon ein video gemacht das könnt
ihr euch gerne hier oben anschauen und
weil sie auch akzeptieren würde wäre
glaube ich ein verbot für
verbrennungsmotoren also vor der
verbrenner autos und das haben zum
beispiel schon holland norwegen
großbritannien china durchgesetzt einige
länder teilweise schon ab 2025 teilweise
ist ab 2040 aber präzedenzfälle gibt es
auf jeden fall dafür und ich glaube das
können wir auch gut überleben und es
würde das ganze noch mal beschleunigen
hin zu alternativen antrieben braucht es
eine ökodiktatur
ich glaube nicht dass man es überlegt
arthur wenden sollte ich bin das ein
sehr polarisieren der begriff aber als
antwort nein ich glaube es würde nicht
helfen wenn wir einfach an der
gesellschaft vorbei regieren denn ich
gerade schon gesagt habe wenn wir kein
verständnis in der gesellschaft haben
dann funktioniert das alles nicht das
haben auch in der aktuellen situation
mit der pandemie gesehen erst wenn die
gesellschaft dahinter steht und das
ganze versteht funktionieren die
maßnahmen und dann braucht man auch
keine diktatur mehr künstliche
intelligenz ist gefährlich erst mal
abwarten super also keines von den
dreien so wirklich erstmal abwarten
würde ich sagen ist falsch wir sollten
da definitiv aktiv mitspielen
wir sollten aber auch definitiv
regulieren und gucken dass das ganze
nicht nach hinten losgeht superjahr
künstlichen lebens kann uns in vielerlei
hinsicht helfen
es ist aber auch gefährlich und wir
sollten definitiv wissen welche
limitierungen künstliche intelligenz hat
deswegen ist die schwierigkeit eine
antwort auszuwählen ich glaube ich mache
trotzdem mal weil die die erwartungen
wird ziemlich groß dann würde ich
trotzdem glaube ich super anklicken ich
bin generell ein optimistischer mensch
erneuerbare energien sind die lösung der
zukunft das problem der zukunft
definitiv die lösung ist es nicht die
einzige lösung im plan aber doch
speicherung von energie und es gibt
viele andere sachen die wir auch noch
brauchen aber wind und photovoltaik sind
definitiv teil der lösung nicht teil des
problems
nach der krise sollte man folgendes
entwickeln und stärken
ok ich glaube wir haben alle gemerkt
internet ist ziemlich wichtig besonders
in der krise wir sollten also definitiv
dem internet ausbau in deutschland
stärken digitalisierung in den schulen
ist auf jeden fall wichtig und haben
gemerkt dass wir da definitiv noch nicht
auf dem stand sind wo wir eigentlich
sein sollten gerade auch die familien
die sich nicht immer die neueste technik
leisten können die müssen unterstützt
werden und ansonsten sollten wir
vielleicht halt gesellschaft ein gefühl
dafür entwickeln dass wir vielleicht
weniger fliegen müssen wir müssen das
nicht ständig machen für business
meetings nach berlin oder was auch immer
vielleicht auch nach china oder sowas
fliegen das funktioniert auch sehr gut
mit video calls und vielleicht sollten
wir auch nicht so bald die pandemie
vorbei ist sofort in den urlaub fliegen
weil wir das so lange jetzt vermisst
haben vielleicht können wir merken dass
wir auch hier in deutschland oder sogar
direkt vor der haustür dinge haben die
uns gut tun was ihr cooles ist dass ihr
euch mit anderen teilnehmerinnen und
teilnehmern vergleichen könnt es gibt
zwischenergebnisse die euch anzeigen
lassen könnt aber ihr könnt euch auch im
menü
die kompletten ergebnisse anzeigen
lassen und da gibt es übrigens auch alle
deutschen und französischen creator
videos zum anschauen unter anderem auch
mainz und ich habe gehört jacob vom
kanal breaking lab ist auch mit dabei
also gerne mal reinschauen und generell
macht mit ist eine sehr coole umfrage
wir brauchen so viele teilnehmerinnen
und teilnehmer wie möglich um die
debatte in gang zu bringen und dinge
nachhaltig zu verändern
ansonsten wie man vielleicht fürs
zuschauen und bleibt wie immer neugierig
patrick